salut je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
ce format nous faisons un focus sur un
point en particulier du cerveau dans
l'épisode précédent vous nous avez
proposé d'aborder notre sens logique et
c'est le sujet du jour
bienvenue dans matière grise
[Musique]
pour cent
passé
dans cet épisode nous allons vivre cinq
expériences expérience une au plus
pressé expérience 2 la logique de la
mémoire expérience 3 mater logique
expérience 4 c'est à vous expérience 5
le tour de luc
le tout avec la présence très appréciée
du magicien québécois luc langevin notre
cerveau est composé de deux hémisphères
distincts qui traitent l'information
comme si le cerveau gauche va traiter de
la raison et de la logique le cerveau 3
d émotion et de la créativité
cette image fut largement popularisé
dans les années 90 mais au final on a
bien qu'un seul et unique cerveau et
l'image du cerveau droit et du cerveau
gauche c'est au mieux justement une
image et au pire un mythe dans notre
cerveau tout et anticipation et
prédictions et pour que cela soit
possible il faut un subtil mélange de
raisonnement analytique et de créativité
mais jusqu'où cela peut aller eh bien on
va voir ça dans l'expérience
alors ce que je te propose luc ne s'est
pas une partie d'échecs
parce que les pièces sont pas du tout
adaptés à mon annonce les proportions
sont bizarres vieux en plus j'étais un
peu favorisés si je prenais les noirs
comme j'ai vu un jeu dans la rue un jeu
un jeu où les gens parient de l'argent
qui se passe par contre avec annie
chéquier et des gobelets le jeu est très
simple
chacun pose des gobelets celui qui a mis
qui n'arrivent plus à placer un gobelet
sans déplacer ceux des autres c'est à
dire que de juste de poser un gobelet
dans un espace restants il a perdu
ok donc ok le but des joueurs c'est
d'essayer de remplir tout l'espace pour
que l'autre n'est plus de place tu
comprends oui ok donc c'est dans la
façon dont on remplit l'espace savak est
donc chacun essaye d'élaborer une
stratégie ou une intuition ou moi j'ai
pas encore décider de comment j'allais
faire mais je me suis ce serait
intéressant de voir comment on aborde ce
problème là toi et moi en jouant l'un
contre l'autre ça marche ça marche qui
me donne un peu de blé ok on en à chacun
la moitié de ses parts fait qu est-ce qu
il
mythe de temps ou deux on y va comme ça
puis écoute moi quand je le vois jouer
dans la rue c'est plutôt dynamique mais
je me dis que c'est aussi avant que la
police arrive mais on peut garder ce
rythme là pour se mettre à leur place de
sakho a été pris par le stress on ferais
comment quoi bonne idée
je commence si tu commences battue je te
laisse une chance je vais commencer je
me sens ok ok je les ai dit si tu y es
ok je vais en mettre un par là je te
laisse trop tranquille va aller chez toi
aussi une bonne idée mais je vais faire
la même chose on va y jeter en valais
ça allait les d'ostersund bouger plus
monsieur largement et
[Musique]
merci aux jeux la main je pense que
c'est déjà fini
je pense que oui bravo
ben voila je crois qu'il faut que tu
ailles clean fabien alors je veux bien
inclinés face à toi mais j'ai quand même
une question avant de le faire c'est un
coup de bol ou vraie stratégie mais je
dois avouer qu'à une vraie stratégie
alors je te croise orthez allait
fonctionner mais visiblement oui donc et
ce alors fléchi moi je t'ai dit ma
stratégie c'était faut que je pose dans
les trous c'est un peu plus que cela
c'est un peu plus élaboré que ça du coup
je suis curieux de connaître la tienne
on va voir ça maclean avant que luc nous
explique sa méthode
essayons de comprendre quelle est sa
logique notre cerveau a besoin d'être
nourri d'expérience pour pouvoir
améliorer sa logique mais attention
quand je dis expérience il faut vraiment
des expériences différentes avec des
sens logique différent des raisonnements
différents pour que notre cerveau puisse
vraiment amélioré le sens logique
globale
si vous ne faites pas cela si vous
utilisez toujours la même méthode de
raisonnement pour la même expérience
alors vous allez simplement vous
spécialiser donc au final comment luc a
fait pour gagner
luc je me suis incliné j'ai le droit à
une explication mais t'inquiète pas ça
sortira pas d'ici très prudent l'optima
tu m'as dit que vraiment à une stratégie
c'est vrai oui je pense que oui en fait
ce que je me suis dit c'est comme c'est
un jeu où on remplit l'espace finalement
j'ai divisé l'échiquier en plusieurs
moitié ici je me dis à chaque fois que
tu prends une espace je remplis l'autre
moitié au final quand tu vas à vue pour
faire le dernier quand toutes les
moitiés vont être remplies il restera
plus rien ah oui
donc l'idée c'est surtout de faire
commencer pour que je puisse reproduire
ce que tu vas faire en fait donc quand
je te laisser commencer en fait ce n'est
pas par eux pour être gentil oui parce
que forcément quand j'aurai fini de
remplir ma moitié
et bien toi et tu resteras un endroit
pour vampire ta moitié si tu fais comme
moi c'est ça oui ça serait ok donc si
par exemple
place est en jeu c'est pas ton gobelet
ici ou départ parce que toi tu es là moi
je suis là il est près de moi à ma
droite
donc moi je fais l'effet un espèce
d'effet miroir sont s'imagine qu'ici il
ya un miroir mais un miroir inversé
soit ça c'est bien et portant des
chapeaux et les sables et ça met les
gens en confiance s'interroge montre que
tu n'as rien préparé voilà ça demande
une vulnérabilité ou par exemple si tu
places ici ce que tu as fait je
m'attends d'ailleurs moi je le place de
façon symétrique si on veut dans le coin
si je retourne de 180 degrés le gobelet
positionner alors d'accord ok en fait
l'idée c'est de le mettre exactement au
même endroit que toi mais de mon côté je
vois comme pilote d'ulm à ta gauche donc
moi je le mets à ma gauche et ensuite
quand tu mets un autre gobelet par
exemple subi ici je fais la même chose
je fais la symétrie mais inversés donc
ça ça donnerait quelque chose comme ça
ici ok ok mais comme tout ça se passe
rapidement on n'a pas le temps j'ai pas
vu j'ai pas vu un schéma ces deux là
pour moi c'est très clair que tout ça
mais en fait j'ai pas vu le schéma se
dessiner parce que je suis dans ma
propre réflexion où on est en speed on
regarde les espaces libres on regarde
pas ou sans les gobelets on regarde les
espaces qui reste quand on joue donc ta
théorie et était bonne la preuve
taghmaoui
alors là je pense que toi tu as eu ce
raisonnement logique parce que tu as un
bagage scientifique qui est réel car
d'ailleurs qu'il nourrit ta magie
absolument
et moi j'aurais mieux fait d'utiliser
les spécificités élire dans des pensées
pour avoir la même démo tjp non mais
tous ont rappelé à chisinau
bon je parie plus jamais avec toi
maintenant qu'on a les explications et
juste avant de passer à l'expérience
numéro 2 je vous informe que cette vidéo
est sponsorisé par part toujours
moi-même en fait problème de placement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le ballon est dévié
qu'est ce qui se passe ça a l'air
d'aller ça va pas du tout j'ai une
diarrhée mental je n'arrête pas de dire
de la merde mais tu ne connais pas
fabien olicard non qu'est ce que c'est
attends ne bouge pas fabien olicard
c'est avant tout un spectacle mêlant
humour et mentalisme et ses riches en
mon talent aux éléments et les en
tournée dans toute la france
bientôt au zénith et bientôt au zénith
ça a l'air super mais je peux pas les en
spectacle dans toute la france tu as
raison xavier mais ne t'inquiète pas il
a tout prévu
il a sorti des livres 3 dont le dernier
votre temps est infini infinie et pas
deux fini
[Rires]
du coup est-ce que je peux le prendre à
emporter au nom est fabien olicard ça se
garde ses personnels notre mémoire une
capacité de stockage estimée à plus de
2,5 péta octets
on voit bien que le problème n'est pas
de stocker de l'information mais d'aller
ensuite la retrouver alors est ce qu'il
existe un sens logique de la mémoire
on va voir ça avec l'udc dans
l'expérience de l'udc je sais que tu
utilise des techniques de mémorisation
tu as déjà vu faire ça en télévision et
puis moi je sais à peu près tout ce que
tu utilises c'est très intéressant pour
stimuler son cerveau mais j'aimerais que
tu oublies tout ça pour aujourd'hui tu
fasse abstraction de toutes ces
techniques
ok pour faire un exercice très simple de
mémoire évidemment avec un jeu de cartes
j'aimerais que dans ce jeu qui est
mélangé turow tiennent ou tu cherche en
tout cas à retenir
l'alternance des cartes rouge et noir
qu'à la fin tu puisse me dire il y avait
une war noir rouge noir ou le vent que
l'alternance que l'alternance comme ça
mais attention sans utiliser les
techniques
j'ai pas besoin de turenne quel est le
nom de la carte qui je sais bizarrement
serait plus simple pour ben c'est ce que
j'allais dire
ok donc que l'alternance rougeret ok je
te laisse te concentrer un petit peu
déçue j'ai combien de temps tu as le
temps que tu veux pour en retenir le
plus possible c'est ça quand j'en aurai
marre j'arrêterai
et puis on va vous laisser faire aussi
essayé n'ont pas de retenir tout le jeu
évidemment mais essayez d'en retenir un
maximum de cette alternance rouge noir
allez-y aucun des partis et c'est un
stop j'ai pas encore le cas chez
d'accord mais je vais arrêter de
regarder ses saillies pour pas très cher
est ce que tu as été à l'aise avec ça de
le faire sans technique ou est-ce que tu
en as trouvé une nouvelle pour le faire
est ce que tu es comme si un stress va
juste essayer de retenir qu en fait
jacques oré c'est la majorité de mon
temps à abyei ne faut pas que ces
techniques ne consent à très injuste
c'est quoi c'est pas évident de
séquences étaient conditionnées mais bon
c'est pas simple du tout je suis
d'accord tout ce que j'ai retenu c'est
noir noir rouge noir rouge noir noir
noir c'est pas mal du tout sa voix soit
dans ta tête tu te répéter en boucle ou
la photographie un peu de mémoire de
travail à tous et je pense c'est ce que
j'ai fait en fait j'ai commencé par
tenir 2 3 que je répétais de trois fois
ensuite je passe à la suite je lui
répétais de trois fois mais
l'apprentissage
on fait tous en fait quand on n'a pas de
technique ben oui on va faire ça mais
j'espère rentrer au fur à mesure la
santé c'est vraiment difficile de faire
abstraction de souci j'avais la prison
c'est plus facile en fait de retenir les
cartes que deux cas juste d'acheter mais
bon oui je suis pas très cher je te jure
je mets je te crois sinon tu m'aurais
dit des 52 donc en fait il faut rendre
votre mémoire il faut trouver une
logique à votre mémoire il faut lui
donner du concret il faut surtout à
organiser des informations comme tu fait
d'une manière haute et là d'une manière
masse n'avait pas forcément une
technique pour s'armer
la meilleure technique c'est de retenir
les nombres de couleurs qui s'enchaînent
par exemple il ya deux noirs je retiens
deux heures je retiens un donc g2j
maintien des chiffres au lieu de deux
il n'a même pas à retenir si c'est noir
rouge parce que comme je sais que ça
chante ça commence par noir à chaque
fois que je vais changer de chiffre je
change de couleur nécessairement donc
j'ai 2 1 1 1 1 tu vois de noir un rouge
un noir un rouge un noir de rouge après
3 noir et on peut composer après son
numéro de téléphone son retient des
séries de trois chiffres par exemple la
moi j'aurais être retenue 211 pour
commencer ce que j'en ai 2 2 une main
une haie vous pouvez vous entraîner à
faire ça pour faire les 52 cartes d'une
manière très rapide parce que vous allez
voir que c'est assez rare qui est des
grandes succession d'une carte une carte
une carte en général y en a toujours
deux trois voire quatre cinq de la même
couleur qui s'enchaînent et quand il ya
cinq cartes
ben c'est quand même 10 % du jeu de
tarot tenue d'un coup en retenant juste
mais oui ça c'est une petite
démonstration que les gens peuvent faire
avant d'accéder à des méthodes aussi
complexe que toi tu utilises et qui
demande quand même énormément
d'entraînement
tu peux déjà tamisée à organiser ta
mémoire comme ça pour t'amuser avec un
jeu de cartes
mais surtout ça vous démontre qu'on peut
tout apprendre
si on trouve une logique pour mémoriser
c'est ça je crois qu'il est important
qu'est ce t'en penses mais jeudi le m
mais at-il e mails non mais c'est toi
aussi maintenu statique des techniques
de mets toi tu cites a fait tomber un
éclat l'absence de réponse à ses lapins
soit là quelqu'un qu'on peut rien dire
pour ça si un éclairage est tombé chez
vous au même moment dites le dans les
commentaires ça peut arriver non
j'allais dire les techniques j'utilise
tous les utiliser mais c'est vrai donc
et quand tu fais là quand tu fais ta
technique ou de sow va-t-il les chiffres
au lieu de l'alternance tu arrives à
retenir que les chiffres ou parce que
moi j'étais porté à retenir les cartes
donc je suis certain en fait que de se
retourner les cartes à jouer plus tôt
alors il est possible
je sais que j'ai retenu les cartes en
même temps que tu as les dix mois au
moins les dix premières cartes juste des
petits première tuvéri fait en même
temps évoqué des dix premières
la première carte c'est 1,5 de pique je
dis ça au hasard juste après c'était un
valet de pique
après c'était la dame de carreau je
crois après c'était le 8 de trèfle après
lutte de trèves c'était le cadre de caro
a précédé le 9 de trèfle après c'était
le valais carreau après c'était le 3 2
carreaux vrai c'était le 10 de pique pas
c'était le cadre de piquet bah c'est ça
toi tu as triché en fait là aussi veut
tricher parce que toi même tu sais que
c'est très compliqué tu vas abstraction
de ça mais même toit judem si tu me dis
tu l'isi bell n'a pas utilisé je sais
que tu as été sincère pour l'alternance
mais je sais qu'il ya des choses que tu
as dû rentrer quand tu connais la 21e
cartes du pack est par exemple il avait
fini 21e là on est à dix après le valet
de coeur tu veux dire que la matière la
baie james et pique je pense la nivelle
et de cartes graphiques à l'art des 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 la nature et
3 pour moi je t'inviterai pour garder le
rythme notre mémoire a besoin de
structurer l'information pour pouvoir la
retenir efficacement pour ça elle doit
la rendre concrètes afin de l'attacher à
des données déjà existants en stock dans
notre cerveau en créant des connexions
entre neurones
alors on peut vraiment utiliser tout son
potentiel mémorielle
[Musique]
rassurez vous il n'est pas question
aujourd'hui de faire les mathématiques
ensemble mais juste de voir comment
quelque chose de si rationnelle peu
comme aime défier notre sens logique
alors mini c'est vous d'une calculatrice
une vraie ou celle de votre téléphone
pour vivre l'expérience 3 donc vous avez
votre calculatrice une vraie ou votre
téléphone portable je vais vous demander
de vérifier qu'elle est bien à 0 pour ça
c'est très simple vous appuyer plusieurs
fois sur la touche assez de la
calculatrice comme ça on est sûr que
c'est à 0 on va essayer de parler trop
vite mais pas trop lentement non plus on
va commencer avec un truc une
information qui faisait personnel vous
allez taper sur la calculatrice votre
pointure de chaussures et voilà c'est un
truc une fois que vous avez votre
pointure de chaussures ou multiplier ce
nombre par saint nic et vous appuyez sur
égale ça doit être fait maintenant donc
maintenant vous taclez +101 +101 et vous
appuyez également sur égale le résultat
que vous obtenez vous le x 20 vous
appuyez sur hegel alors il reste plus
qu'une étape jouera sur qui va être avec
un élément de votre vie encore plus
personnel maintenant vous appuyez sur -
et vous tapez votre année de naissance
en quatre chiffres motion en 1982 donc
jette après 1982 et vous appuyez sur
régal et là qu'est ce qui se passe l'udc
si vous regardez le résultat que vous
obtenez probablement que ça vous dit
rien en particulier mais porter
attention aux deux premiers chiffres
vous allez reconnaître votre pointure
et si vous regardez les deux derniers
chiffres ça représente fort probablement
l'âge que vous allez avoir cette année
cette année en 2020 parce qu'au final
c'est pas si magique c'était surtout
logique
alors pourquoi ce résultat fonctionne et
surtout pourquoi on en n'a pas compris
la logique spontanément notre logique se
nourrit de ce qu'on lui donne un élément
extérieur et de ce qu'il ya à
l'intérieur de notre mémoire à savoir
des données et des raisonnements si elle
ne trouve pas de comparaison immédiate à
faire alors elle ne peut pas trouver une
logique spontanée le calcul que nous
venons de faire est une complexification
d'un calcul super simple au final 101 x
20 c'est égal à 2020 et si je vous avais
dit 2020 tout de suite vous auriez tout
de suite pensé que c'était l'année en
cours et 2020 - votre âge ça vous donne
l'âge que vous allez avoir en 2020 si je
vous l'avais dit comme ça là aussi vous
auriez eu la logique de trouver que
c'était ça pour la pointure on l'a x
sens puisqu'on a fait 5 fois 20 si on
regarde la manière dont les formules et
le calcul donc votre pointure x sens à
fait votre pointure suivi de 2,0 et
votre pointure suivi de 2 0 additionnées
avec le résultat précédent ça nous donne
un nombre à quatre chiffres
les deux de gauche sans votre pointure
les deux de droite lâche que vous allez
avoir cette année c'est aussi logique
que ça attention c'est à vous dans cette
expérience nous allons mettre votre sens
logique à l'épreuve
je voulais dit c'est à vous mais c'est
aussi un petit peu à nous luc et moi on
a préparé chacun de notre côté
deux questions qu'on va vous poser mais
on va aussi se les poser entre nous
l'udc c'est des questions de logique et
qui demande une manière de réfléchir en
tout cas sûrement différentes les unes
des autres
je te propose de me poser d'abord ta
première après je poserai les miennes et
tu fermera la marche si cette banque est
en marche oui alors nous écoutons
d'accord écoute fabien imagine
une horloge willeman autres et voici ma
question combien de fois les aiguilles
d'une montre se chevauchent dans une
journée
d'accord donc on parle d'une journée de
24 heures il y aura deux tours de cadran
du coup oui ok voilà et puis on peut
supposer qu'on va commencer à 00h01 à
00h01 ouais ok combien de fois la petite
et de la grande aiguille vont se
chevaucher dans le 24 heures alors je
vous laisse vous aussi chercher mais
spontanément j'ai une réponse qui me
semble logique
ce qui me fait toujours peur dans ce
genre de questions quand ça paraît
logique c'est ce n est pas forcément
mais mettez votre réponse à vous dans
les commentaires aussi comme ça on va
comparer ça veut dire ici on commence à
00h01
j'enlève le premier croisement donc elle
se croiseront 23 fois en 24 heures ce
serait probablement la réponse la plus
populaire mais c'est la mauvaise réponse
en fait la bonne réponse c'est 22 et
c'est extrêmement contre intuitif
en fait c'est tellement contre intuitif
que genre des difficultés à vous
l'expliquer mais en fait ce qui est ce
qui est trompeur c'est que comme la
petite aiguille avant soucis à mesure
que leurs progrès skis les deux
aiguilles ne se chevauchent jamais
vraiment au même endroit et en fait au
bout de 24 heures on perd en quelque
sorte tous deux à sept a créé un
décalage sur les croisements à wimbledon
est ce que ça va se croiser de plus en
plus loin et ça saute un moment ça saute
un moment s'est immiscé trek en effet
dès que je passe les dessins en fait
c'est la meilleure façon de le faire
c'est de dessiner
si tu veux jeanne de ou en 24 cercle et
de tracer les aiguilles à chaque fois
qu'elles vont se chevaucher les gens
vous trouvez une image de ça on va on va
le regarder on le fait apparaître à
l'écran
d'accord maintenant je sais pas s'il ya
des gens qui font des entrevues
d'embauché et c'est une sorte de test
qu'ils font et pose cette question aux
gens et comme justement c'est très
difficile a figuré
logiquement ils veulent simplement voir
la réaction de la personne à ce que la
personne va répondre en temps dément une
connerie en défendant corps et la
manière d'en cherchant escapade
méthodologique puisqu'elle va être
honnête je sais pas où donc ça on en
apprend beaucoup sur la personne
finalement quand on veut c'est vrai on
voit sa réaction face à une énigme comme
celle là et ces baisses et passionnant
jeu du coup la biennale est moins
passionnante
ok c'est pas ou parce que j'ai pas
vraiment moi j'ai une question qui m'a
l'air
je pense qu'elle est plus simple mais
imagine j'ai une pièce grande pièce avec
moi juste à côté dans cette grande pièce
il ya 100 personnes qui nous attendent
c'est bizarre avant que tu as fait ça
parce que il était très heureux que tu
aies sur la en france et qui reviennent
faire fait chaud ici
ses parents eux mais ils attendent à
côté mais ils ont une spécificité
si j'en prends 2 ou hasard dans la pièce
ok j'ai forcément l'un des deux qui a
les cheveux bruns dire que j'en prends
deux sur l'île il ya forcément un des
deux cas les cheveux bruns pas forcément
les deux et puis je leur mets dans la
pièce je reprends deux personnes au
hasard il ya forcément à des deux qui a
les cheveux bruns
ok du coup ma question c'est combien il
ya de personnes qui ont les cheveux
bruns dans la pièce en fait j'ai
l'impression pour vraiment que tu as ton
affirmation soit juste il faudrait que
presque toujours en fait pas tout le
monde pourrait 4 99 personnes qu'elles
les cheveux bruns et que une personne à
dos de cheveux mais parce que c'est ça
se sache or on se tape aussi difficile a
précisé qu'il ouvre la mecque et
scientifique de base mais norbert narach
vrai t'as fait non moi ce qui
m'impressionne c'est comment tu as
trouvé 99 personnes qui ont les cheveux
l'autre pierre suesser beaucoup plus
précieux bien mais de là où tu as été
bon c'est que t'as retourné je pense le
problème à l'envers de te poser la
question combien personne n'avait pas
les cheveux bruns parce que
intuitivement pour le coup la plupart
des personnes ont envie de répondre la
moitié 50% puisqu'on reste sur
l'information de puisqu'il ya toujours
au moins un sur deux tu dis ok il ya la
moitié de la pièce mais non parce que je
pourrais prendre deux personnes blonde
donc c'est une bonne question je vais
tout de suite enchaîné la deuxième parce
que ça m'agace imagine qu'on reçoit en
2020 ça c'est pas trop dur ça je peux le
figuré bien et 2020 c'est une année
bissextile parce qu'on peut diviser dans
cette année par quatre qui se connaît
cette astuce pour lui qui peut diviser
l'année par quatre ce qu'elle est
bissextile eh bien ma question et si
dans une année bissextile
il y avait cinq dimanches en février
quel serait le premier jour du mois de
février
parce que ce sera lundi à mardi un
incendie dimanche
mercredi non je ne sais pas en fait la
manche aller me suis dit je veux redire
ici c'est bon je vais avoir l'air d'un
génie sinon bon tant pis non mais j'ai
pas l'impression que c'est très
difficile a figuré en fait en réalité
c'est un dimanche
ouais vous il ya dix jours la réponse
c'est un dimanche qui et pourquoi
mais en fait c'est un peu comme porter
aiguilles tout à l'heure c'est à peu
près le même genre de questions c'est à
dire qu' on n'est pas assez habitués à
manipuler déjà quelque chose qui marche
par sept et le jour de la semaine et les
mois et c'est pour ces fréquences et
toute la logique qui va avec on n'a pas
cette logique là mais parce que on ne
s'en sert pas on le manipule pas parce
qu'on n'a pas de nécessité
donc on n'a pas ce sens logique là et
c'est en ça que le sens logique qui ce
travail de plein de manières différentes
dans quelques secondes on n'a pas de
référent n'a rien à seppois travail et
je pense que la seule manière d'aboutir
à un résultat de tête c'est de se dire
ok si ça commence lundi et que je fais
plus cette puce est +77 combien je cale
de semaine si je commence par un mardi
et par élimination en plus tu vas te
faire toute la semaine parce que c'est
paru dimanche
merci non non c'est très compliqué je te
propose de me poser la dernière hockey
imagine que
de père et deux fils vont acheter des
chapeaux combien de chapeaux qu'elles
température fétiche en autobus à voilà
n'ont donc de père et deux fils vont
acheter des chapeaux combien de chapeau
h et il tu as le choix de réponses
ok est ce que la bonne réponse c'est 4
ou est ce que la bonne réponse et 4 ou
moins ou est ce que la bonne réponse
c'est 4 ou plus ok donc quatre 4 mois ou
4 ou plus
voilà donc ça veut dire qu'il ya pas une
réponse figée parce que si c'était le
cas je crois qu'ils me poserait pas la
question donc ses 4o ans 4 au plus une
bonne discussion comme ça peuvent être
plus de 4 donc ses quatre roues - ah oui
d'accord ok je les c4 ou moins ok
pourquoi parce que il pourrait y avoir
que trois personnes walla walla si on a
des trois générations d'une même famille
octobre ça ok tu cites a un grand père
balzeau opère son fils et son petit-fils
finalement on a quand même deux fils et
on a quand même deux paires mais ne sont
que trois personnes le père et père le
grand père et père du père voilà petit
fils et fils du père et le père c'est le
fist au service de reprendre mais pour
le coup je crois que tout le monde a dû
la comprendre spontanément une fois
qu'il ou elle tu imagines est elle allée
génial parce que je trouve qu'en plus
elle symbolise linverse de ce que je
disais juste avant c'est à dire que on
est habitué à manipuler les générations
familiales
on sait ce que c'est un père un grand
père et ces machins donc ce n'était pas
si difficile pour moi de voir les
configurations parce que c'est une
logique qu'on connaît nous le logique
généalogique on va dire quoi faire dites
nous dans les commentaires
combien de bonnes réponses vous aviez
sur les 4 mettez nous c'est en
pourcentage 25 50 75 ou 100 comme ça ça
ferait un peu plus scientifique
j'aime bien
le genre de questions que vous venez de
vivre à l'instant sont parfois utilisés
par des recruteurs lors des entretiens
d'embauché
elle stimule votre logique et votre
manière de raisonner parfois
différemment alors je vous rassure pour
les recruteurs le but n'est pas d'avoir
la bonne réponse mais c'est de pouvoir
observer votre attitude quand vous êtes
en train de raisonner alors faire ce
genre de jeu au delà d'améliorer la
logique vous offre deux cadeaux de la
dopamine et de la sérotonine notre
cerveau joue avec quatre substances
chimiques endogène c'est à dire produit
par notre propre cerveau pour s'auto
récompensé l'endorphine nous est
délivrée lorsqu'on vient de faire du
sport par exemple au moins 30 minutes ou
lorsqu'on est en train de rigoler
pendant un certain temps
ces lits en tout cas au physique
l'ocytocine elle est délivrée lors d'une
interaction sociale par exemple quand on
fait un câlin quelqu'un ou quand on
reçoit un compliment ou même quand on
reçoit un like sur les réseaux sociaux
par exemple la dopamine
elle est délivrée lorsqu'on relève un
défi et qu'on réussit à relever le défi
c'est ce qui se passe quand on met notre
sens logique en marche et enfin la
sérotonine qui elle est délivrée pour
réguler notre humeur pour l'expérience 5
j'ai demandé à l'udc de nous préparer un
tour de magie de sa spécificité
parce que l'udc c'est un magicien
différent il a un gros bagage
scientifique
il s'en sert pour faire des tours de
magie différents en clair il va faire
quelque chose de complètement logique
qui va défier notre sens rationnel alors
je sais pas du tout ce qui nous a
préparé et je vais découvrir ça avec
vous maintenant
tu sais peut-être tout ce qui nous
entoure et effet d'atomes de particulier
il ya énormément de vie dedans c'est
particulier autour d'elle ce qui fait
que si on aligne les particules d'un
objet avec les vides de notre objet on
peut littéralement faire passer les
objets 1 à travers l'autre sans les
abîmer
tu vas voir à ce sujet la fabien à ce
que tu as des objets des objets qu'on
pourrait utiliser serviettes de table ne
fauche est pas extraire en fait comme tu
m'as dit que j'étais en pose moi je
mangeais du chou ben oui c'est bien pour
toi le jeu vous est d'offrir une
fourchette sépare fun serviettes qui est
à peu près propre encore du chou non bah
ça on n'en aura pas besoin pour le tour
donc j'ai de l'eau j'ai avec mes deux
voilà c'est parfait c'est les
accessoires les plus propres comme un
commandant permis d'utiliser fanny si tu
veux tu peux regarder les accessoires
mais c'est vraiment des accessoires
comme on les connaît et on va également
utiliser un élastique juste ici d'accord
que je pose près de toi et je vois que
tu as plusieurs bagues aux doigts
je vais retirer les miennes pour paquet
confusion et à ce que je pourrais être
emprunté 10 ans celle là ici elle va
être plus visible je crois très jolie
est ce que est ce que c'est un cadeau ou
un cap et un cadeau d'accord donc je
vais faire très attention
je fermais doigt par dessus la bague
juste comme ça et je me permette de
couvrir mon poing et a bag avec la
serviette de table juste comme ça et je
vais te demander fanni je te prêter
l'élastique juste ici et j'aimerais
fanny que tu utilises pour enrober en
fait ma main et avec la serviette de
table pour en faire une espèce de
pochettes voilà avec l'élastique ouais
c'est ça peut même faire plusieurs tours
si tu veux ou un seul essai à tanis
parfait et peut saisir la fourchette
avec ta main juste ici oui et l'autre
bout avec toi autrement parfait ne bouge
pas fanny et voit comment une bague peut
passer à travers une serviette de table
et une fourche c'est impossible
ça m'agace et toi il n'y a pas de trou
dans la serviette de table j'ai même je
dirais ça ici il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
de décision sur tabakh tout et tout et
la soif annie si je vais reprendre
tabacstop permettre je sais que tu aimes
tant de la fourchette mais je vais te
montrer parce que on peut observer le
phénomène beaucoup plus facilement avec
un élastique
tu sais parce que un élastique lorsqu'on
me tire un élastique
en fait on éloigne chacune des
particules qui le constituent et on
facilite le phénomène regardera d'eux
même temps comme atteints mais comme sa
famille l'une des deux parfaits et tu
poses ça juste ici tu peux fermer tes
doigts par dessus ou la main ils se
battent eux permettre de récupérer ta
bague mais on laisse à l'élastique et
actes
merci fred esata plus à leur permet de
revenir parce que je pense qu'elle
verrait te planter la fourchette
vraiment nous on s'est posé la question
derrière les caméras de dieu c'est ouf
merci l'avais jamais vu faire avec la
fourchette la serviette il estime que
j'avais vus non non non non il haïssait
incroyable t'es pas content tu es
ronchon tu es là pour apprécier ça il
faut justement décrocher notre sens
logique parce que notre sens logique qui
peut plus suivre
et si on essaie qui suivent on devient
tout rouge et on croise les doigts bravo
à luc mercier t-mobile c'était vraiment
excellent nous on sait qu'on peut te
voir
en france on peut te voir sur diversion
date d émission de télé comme ça on peut
devoir aussi sur sa chaîne youtube sur
ton facebook sur ton instagram un petit
peu partout j'ai même peur des fois
quand je me retourne dans la rue de te
voir on c'est vrai je suis là je te
surveille faible mais j'ai eu le plaisir
de te voir sur scène c'était au casino
de paris et un spectacle incroyable
parce que il va piocher dans plainte
d'univers de la magie que tu réunis
autour de ta spécificité qui est un peu
l'univers scientifique et c'est très
très chouette du coup ma question est
quand est-ce qu'on peut te revoir nous
en france écoute je vais être au casino
de paris du 21 au 31 janvier 2021
smockey rompt pas donc on est en
résidence de semaine puis en tournée un
peu un peu partout dans la france fin
2020 début 2021 avec mon spectacle
maintenant demain le spectacle gratuit
de l'adij mélange la science mais pour
faire rêver pour rapporter de l'émir et
puis on a une téléportation qui est
incroyable je vous spoile pas mais je
vous fais avoir deux images ce rêve le
poids voilà c'est juste fou à voir sur
scène et sûrement à vivre quand tu es
spectateur j'ai pas eu l'occasion de le
livre moi mais voilà c'est un combat tu
viendras je vais embarquer dans les
coffres c'est déstabilisant d'ouvrir
jette dans la neige avec trois quarts
elle bougeait beaucoup moins on met un
lien vers tout ça dans la description
vers tous les réseaux vers la chaîne
youtube
j'espère que ce troisième épisode de
matière grise vous à +6 7 capes pense
évidemment à liker cette vidéo et à la
partager dans la description vous avez
un lien vers les deux premiers épisodes
lui avec benjamin verica et celui avec
enjoy phoenix merci à luc langevin des
devenu depuis le québec aujourd'hui pour
faire ce tournage là avec moi c'était
très cool je mets un lien vers sa chaîne
évidemment dans la description et vous
pouvez aussi vous abonner à cette chaîne
l'a tant que vous êtes là et activer la
cloche parce qu'il n'y a pas de date de
sortie de vidéos donc elles peuvent pop
et n'importe quand vous pouvez aussi me
dire évidemment
quels sujets vous voulez pour le
matériel grise numéro 4 dans les
commentaires ils sont tous lui est
fortement appréciée alors si on peut
éduquer notre sens logique jusqu'à quel
point pouvons nous pousser notre
capacité à anticiper les choses
vous aurez la réponse à cette question
il ya bien d'autres dans les prochains
épisodes de matière grise
à très bientôt ciao